okay last week I announced that we would
be giving away six free memberships for
one year and the context was that this
guy who goes by the the handle gr who
regularly participates in our YouTube
live streams he regularly sends comments
that are basically what we've called
incoherent rants now they're not hatred
mail they are
I guess generally positive to the extent
that I have any clue at all what it is
that's being said he offered to sponsor
six memberships for a year and what we
decided was that we would basically open
up the email inbox to people who want to
submit their own rant in the style of GR
and that we would decide on the best six
of them and give away six free
memberships okay so reminder once again
these are not hatred mail here are two
example incoherent rants from gr and
I'll read these as best I can and again
it's tough for me to even really
understand them here's the first one
packed easy take it from the top bring
us to the progressive pastors of green
emerald utopia science fiction us to a
trump las' world love gr okay that's one
example again not hatred mail but mostly
unintelligible here's another one maybe
more representative of a typical gr
ramped its time bonus show or Co me flow
don't own up to we who call that session
testimony just a session full of old
baloney
Spanky like Trump the nasty face so
orange he matched the prison jammies
okay that's how we set it up Pat now I
didn't know exactly what to expect
we received dozens of submissions from
people who decided I would say probably
in the three in the triple digits like
over a hundred submissions and I've
narrowed it down to the six winners okay
now as always people will hear this and
they'll say mine was better than one of
those many factors were taken into
consideration a complex algorithm was
used to determine who the winners were
in both vocabulary pacing length context
subject matter yeah all of those things
were taken into consideration so here
are the six winners who are getting
free david pakman show membership
courtesy of incoherent rancer gr first
and foremost is Roberto Katella who
wrote in saying Trump is first among
buffoons
Spicer's press briefing a bunch of
balloons bannon's got less friends than
Saturn's got moons tired of American
politics should be the title of world
headlines now even the French can
ridicule us without feeling guilty while
innocent Saudi go around policing
naughty Qatari and Yemen rebels luckily
enough TPP is gone so at last Mexico and
Canada can go after each other without
pretending we don't exist because we
don't this was a nice balance between
timely political subject matter
combined with endless run-on sentences
and bizarre sentence structure that is
one of our winners of a free membership
yeah I feel like it's when you're in
high school and you have to read a poem
and really provide some sort of literary
analysis yeah through with a highlighter
and a few pens to really understand the
author's intent a few pens would have
liked to have been a fly on the wall in
Pat's English class see what's going on
in there okay next winner Christian joy
Zilla
who said the dream wait no hold on we
skipped over one there about here we go
Christian Christian joy Villa the dream
Pat us down with your gentle vegan votes
voice your Keurig filled fanny packs
table Becky the soul to feeling
everlasting Pat sessions we don't recall
Pat no cheesy the spices hidden so spice
up that world in which all existence
dreams Trump golf forbidden so this one
a vegan producer Pat themed incoherent
rant very very good that was a good
approach because obviously you're going
to win no doubt about it absolutely
Jonathan MacGyver is our third winner
who wrote Patriots mentioned David's
Jewish heritage like they want a star on
his chest he's an honest media man
though he hasn't drunk the cob feffy
like all the rest they ain't got nothing
to say about David and Pat and the bonus
show is where it's at clever clever to
mention membership benefits
probably helped that is next winner I
mean he did misspelled hatreds
yes but they look out of it okay our
next winner is burned psyche sir who
wrote punch up to that who's orange
Hitler bro with that sick call me
coherence flow because he a dum-dum Reid
can no tax return revealed this corrupt
to the next cell then he feeling that
infrared magenta magma inhale like the
failing fake news Lion King scar from
burning ground progressive Phoenix comes
then Simba in Pride Rock America from
hyena trumpets a lot of imagery from The
Lion King and I like that that was also
an interesting approach this would make
some great slam poetry that's the kind
of thing you have to deliver in front of
a whole group of people oh yeah
absolutely and there should probably be
some musical accompaniment to that
alright our 5th winner is Erik Erik with
a Q when David was a little boy growing
up in the fields of Worcestershire sauce
he used to get so mad when I would take
the bull by the horns because he wanted
the candy corns and all the king's
horses and all the king's men couldn't
grab them by the pretty sure everyone
you know has been using russian salad
dressing on your greens for a minute now
hashtag unprecedented
okay so resident right but well they did
it in unlike as a no precedent no
precedent uh okay I hope I think though
that was a trump reference exactly and
also a Massachusetts reference the land
of Worcestershire sauce of course we're
talking about Worcester although I don't
know if Worcestershire sauce is actually
from Worcester Mass it's not right yeah
Oakland City in England I think - right
well of course absolutely all right and
finally the sixth and final recipient of
a free membership courtesy of incoherent
ranter gr is Jake oka sessions imploding
approval late approval rates lowering
YouTube boycott silencing the Afro man
David and sidekick Pat nobody can
silence Trump's Russian compliance face
so jank look like a rotten sweet potato
he think there isn't an alliance working
defiance but he don't know use coupon
code I've voted 17 for 40% off of your
membership very very good wrap up
they're referencing the coupon code six
winners thank you to gr for providing us
this opportunity in sponsoring the six
memberships we already have our next
membership sponsorship lined up that's
going to be in July and it will be
patriotism themed around the fourth of
July so this is a really great thing and
we can't thank gr enough you can email
in if you are one of the six winners we
will also email you probably within the
next 24 hours